hello and welcome i'm james murphy. did you
know that not all exceptions in python derive
from the built-in Exception class? that's
right not all exceptions are Exceptions.
this is almost correct though, let's see what
happens if we try to raise something that's
not an Exception. here i try raising a string and
i get an error message that says all exceptions
must derive from BaseException, not Exception.
okay so all exceptions have to be BaseExceptions,
but what's the difference between a BaseException
and an Exception? well here's the official
documentation. a BaseException is just the
base class for all built-in exceptions.
on the other hand, a plain old Exception is for
all built-in non-system exiting exceptions, and
all user-defined exceptions. clearly
the python documentation is telling
me that for my own exceptions i should be
inheriting from Exception not BaseException.
so what are the built-in system exiting
exceptions that it's talking about here?
we can find out a little bit lower in the
documentation by looking at the exception
class hierarchy. from this list we can see that
python has only three built-in exceptions that
are BaseExceptions but not Exceptions.
looking at the first two, now we know
what the authors of the documentation meant
when they said non-system exiting exceptions.
SystemExit and KeyboardInterrupt generally cause
your python program to stop. GeneratorExit on the
other hand doesn't cause your program to stop
and i'm not quite sure why it's a BaseException
and not just an Exception. my intuition tells
me that it should go wherever StopIteration
goes, but i'm sure there were good reasons for
doing this. but let's move on and stick with
the main intent of separating BaseException from
Exception. let's investigate why it's useful to
separate exiting exceptions from non-exiting ones.
consider the following example. suppose somewhere
deep down in our code something fails and we
want to exit the program, so we call sys.exit.
here we've wrapped the whole thing in a try
except where we're catching all Exceptions.
as you can see none of the print statements
execute. that's because sys.exit raised a
SystemExit exception which is a BaseException, not
an Exception. what we're assuming here and what is
normally the case when you're programming is that
for exceptions you want to catch logical errors or
failures of functions to succeed. handling these
kind of business logic exceptions is generally
what you mean to do when you use a try except.
this is a very different type of situation than
what's going on if somewhere in the code someone
tries to exit the program. generally speaking,
if someone's trying to exit the program you
really shouldn't be stopping them. now of course
you can catch a SystemExit if you want to do
something specific in that situation, but normally
when you say catch all the exceptions. this is not
what you have in mind. if you want to catch *all*
the exceptions, then you just use a bare except or
an except BaseException. keep in mind though that
in my opinion catching all exceptions is almost
always a bad idea. in my opinion you should always
prefer to use the most specific kind of exception
that you can think of. if you expect a TypeError
or a ValueError then use them. don't depend on
except BaseException or except Exception to just
catch everything. i know it's really tempting to
just use a bare except because it's less to type.
using a bare except or an except Exception is way
too broad and it will often lead to catching and
possibly silently handling errors that you weren't
expecting. like here i passed the wrong kind of
argument to sys.exit, but during the execution
of the program i have no way of knowing that.
moving on, let's see what can go wrong if you
do try to catch all exceptions instead of just
non-system-exiting ones. so i'm going ahead
and running this program, it's doing work,
it's doing work, it's doing work, and i decide
that it's taking too long. i want to kill this
program so i go ahead and hit ctrl c and try to
kill it. no matter how many times i hit ctrl c
the exception handler is not allowing me to exit
the program. if i want to kill the program, i have
to kill the terminal itself, or kill the python
process at the operating system level. however
if i just catch Exceptions, then i can kill it
with ctrl c, and i get a KeyboardInterrupt. this
is a common mistake that people make especially
when accepting user input from the terminal. as
a side note, if you really just want to kill
python and not ask it to shut down nicely,
you can do that using the os._exit function.
you can see that when we run this code nothing
is printed out because python is killed. it
doesn't raise an exception like sys.exit does,
os._exit just kills the program. most of the
time, you only really want to do this after you
forked a new process and then want to kill it,
but it's good to know just in case you have to.
finally, what's the deal with GeneratorExit?
GeneratorExit is not a system-exiting exception
but it is a BaseException, not a Exception. a
GeneratorExit is raised inside a generator when
you call the generator's close function before the
generator is finished. here we create a generator
and call its next method once. it just yielded
0 and now it's paused. while it's paused we call
its close method and we see that gen exit is
printed out. we see gen exit printed because
the GeneratorExit was caught by this exception
handler. notice however that we re-raised the
exception but we still don't see a trace back.
that's because much like a StopIteration used
in for loops, a GeneratorExit is not really
an error. a generator raising GeneratorExit
is just python's way of telling you that the
generator is done. python silently handles a
GeneratorExit just like it silently handles a
StopIteration for a for loop. again, honestly
i'm not sure why this is a BaseException and not
an Exception. in any case though that's all of
the built-in BaseExceptions in python that aren't
themselves Exceptions. you can technically make
your own BaseExceptions by inheriting directly
from BaseException but the documentation tells
you that you shouldn't do this. well that's all
i've got on exceptions, thanks for watching. i
hope you learned a little bit. if you liked
the video please consider subscribing, share
it with your friends, and as always slap that like
button an odd number of times. see you next time.